if you're a fan of lovable goofball ryan
reynolds and if you're not you're going
to want to get your funny bone checked
and you've got to be psyched for free
guy one of the most ridiculously awesome
looking movies of recent years
here's everything we know about the
movie so far before we dig into the
juicy details let's get this out of the
way
free guy was originally meant to open
wide in theaters on july 3
2020. unless you've been living under a
rock or have been isolated for quite
some time you probably have a pretty
strong inkling about why free guy was
delayed
for a while after being bumped from its
original date it seemed like free guy
was locked in for a december 11th 2020
release date but that didn't happen
either
the movie's current release date
assuming nothing happens to bump it
again
is august 13th 2021 free guy is one of
the first major films to be released
under the new banner of 20th century
studios
the moniker bestowed upon the former
20th century fox after its acquisition
by disney
the house of mouse buried its approach
to its releases that were originally
slated for 2020 while the studio pushed
back the premiere dates of tentpole
films like the live-action mulan remake
and marvel's black widow
it didn't do so until it became clear
that such a move was necessary
in the case of free guy a delay was
certainly the best course of action
and the fact that the studio went so far
as to push it into summer 2021
is a strong signal that they believe it
will do well in theaters
free guy is directed by knight of the
museum helmer sean levy from a
screenplay by matt lieberman and zach
penn a veteran scribe who has worked on
everything from men in black to the
avengers
their cast is riddled with ringers
several of whom were cast largely due to
their connections to the video game
world
popping up and supporting roles or
cameos will be youtuber tyler ninja
blevins twitch star
iman pokeman and ease let's play
favorite lana laser beam ecot and sean
jacksepticeye mclaughlin who will be
voicing the iconic video game character
q bert
since that character speaks nearly
exclusively in bleeped curses this
should be interesting
what's he saying felix stand by my
kubernetes is a little rusty
the familiar faces don't end there
appearing in the main caster thor
ragnarok director taika waititi is video
game developer antoine
killing eaves jody coomer as programmer
millie and her in-game alter ego molotov
girl stranger things star joe kiri as
programmer keys
and get out actor lil raul howry is
guy's fellow npc
and friend buddy one thing we're
extremely curious about is who or what
will serve as the in-game big bad
while guy will be working against
external forces to keep his world from
collapsing it stands the reason that
i'll have some kind of virtual nemesis
to contend with as well
but as far as who or what that villain
could be we still don't know
the story of free guy has had a long
road to theaters even before the
pandemic delays
deadline reported back in 2016 that the
film back then described as a matt
lieberman spec script in the vein of the
truman show had acquired the highly
sought after deadpool star ryan reynolds
the overall plot seems to have remained
the same since then but given reynold's
star power and his love of getting
creatively involved in his projects it's
likely that the movie's tone evolved
from there to match his personality and
talents
and while reynolds wasn't one of the
initial creators of the project it's
clear that he fell deeply in love with
it
in 2019 he said i haven't been this
fully immersed and engaged in something
since deadpool
i think we live in really weird times
right now you're watching the news and
the top story today is
it's the end of the world i felt a
kinship to the character in that you can
sometimes feel like a background
character
the world is on loop and you have no
control over what's happening
that sounds like a fascinating theme to
explore through comedy and we're
intrigued to see how free guy tackles
the idea of an npc facing an existential
crisis
but beyond the broad themes and premise
we actually don't know much about the
movie's plot
although the trailers give us a good
idea of what to expect the first trailer
is
simply put gloriously bonkers set to the
bouncy strains of mariah carey's fantasy
it shows a look at a typical day in
guy's life
that leads to a snap decision to
suddenly involve himself in the mayhem
that results in his world turning upside
down and his reaction to his realization
that his world isn't exactly
you know real we also get an idea of the
excellent comedic chemistry between
reynolds and comer
along with an abundance of explosions
gunfights and wild stunts
it's not like ryan reynolds has a
conflicted history when it comes to
those sort of things
answer as quickly as you can now if you
had a gun to your head
the second trailer for free guy is just
as jam-packed with awesomeness as its
predecessor but offers a more concrete
sense in the movie's narrative guy is a
background character of a video game who
learns he isn't real
and ventures to become the hero of his
world and save it from impending doom
the third trailer places further
emphasis on the character of molotov
girl and the role she plays in the plot
it seems she will be instrumental in
guys development from clueless npc to
self-aware action hero
of course although there's a lot we can
figure out from the trailers there's a
lot more we don't know
in addition to our questions about the
movie's main villain we also wonder just
how jody comer's dual character will
figure in
she's been presented as an in-game ally
to guy but she's also one of the game's
programmers in the real world
with this in mind it sure seems like she
could have a key role to play in
convincing taika white tt's developer
character not to pull the plug on the
game
but beyond guy's gradual evolution into
a hero the details of the story of free
guy remain a mystery
that's probably a good thing as we feel
like this is going to be a flick that's
full of hilarious and inspired surprises
most likely the less you know the more
enjoyable it will all be
and based on the trailer so far we have
a solid idea of its overall vibe which
is every bit as hilarious as you would
hope for it to be
that's not huge jackman though no it
sure isn't that's like five foot nine
wolvie from the comics
yeah that's real wolverine yeah hugh
jackman kind of outdid himself never
heard of him
considering the video game themed plots
including a number of game references
cameos and more it goes without saying
that if there's a prime audience for
free guy it's the gaming community
there's so many callbacks to the games
that we know and love
you're going to be really excited to see
it however ryan reynolds has fans all
over the place some of whom may have
never even held a game controller
will these people get lost not according
to reynolds during a 2019 press
conference reynolds drew a comparison to
sports movies and how even people who
might have no interest in say
an actual baseball game can still be
thrilled by a baseball movie
in his words i always look at it like
sports movies are good metaphors
the greatest sports movies ever made are
not actually about sports
field of dreams i wouldn't characterize
that as a baseball story they used
baseball as a vehicle to tell a really
beautiful story about a son and a father
trying to connect
i think that we're doing the same thing
director sean levy added that the
movie's central conceit about an npc who
is just finding out that he is in a game
means that the ideal audience surrogate
is actually a non-gamer
a non-gaming audience will easily be
able to place themselves in guy's shoes
as he learns all about what video games
are and how they work
so all gamers will be thrilled with all
the inside jokes and fun twists on
things they love
the whole high concept premise is really
just there to tell a more universal
story
and honestly if audiences could figure
out the matrix back in 1999 they should
be more than ready for free guy
not that long ago there wouldn't be a
question about whether a major studio
release would play in theaters or not
things have changed a lot since 2020
though and these days there's always
some question about whether a movie will
release in theaters or if it'll go right
to streaming or in some cases if it'll
go up on both simultaneously so where
does it fall in this new entertainment
landscape
it looks like free guy is taking full
advantage of the reopening of theaters
nationwide thanks to increasing
vaccination rates and lowering covert
restrictions
in fact just like in the pre-covet era
free guy will release exclusively in
theaters for the first 45 days of its
run
this is in contrast to some of disney's
other big releases such as corella and
black widow which debuted in theaters
and on disney plus simultaneously
but it looks like disney's release
strategy is beginning to shift
free guy comes out in august just a few
weeks ahead of the studio's next big
release shang chi and the legend of the
10 rings
clearly disney is banking on earning big
bucks with this movie and on theaters
coming back in a big way
given the enthusiasm that free guy has
earned all over the internet so far and
the public's excitement to return to
movie theaters this seems like a good
bet on their part
we'll see if their plan pays off when
free guy hits theaters on august 13
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
[Music]
one